je suis un amorti et professeur à
l'école des médias de l'uqam madame
lortie bonsoir qu'est ce qu'on doit
comprendre quel est le message de pierre
lapointe qu'est ce qu'on doit retirer de
ce message bien pierre lapointe je pense
un cas la perte de confiance des
artistes la musique si au québec envers
ces outils merveilleux qui était et qui
sont encore d'ailleurs les plateformes
de diffusion de musique en continu perte
de confiance aussi envers les nombreux
gouvernements qui se sont penchés sur le
sujet de la fiscalité des plateformes
des redevances et de l'encadrement
réglementaire et qui n'ont pas agi et
donc et expliquez nous comment
fonctionne le mécanisme de
redistribution des revenus de la
diffusion en continu
alors chaque écoute chaque screens et
comptabilisés et ensuite est mis dans un
pot et ce sont le total de tous les
strings nom de tous les artistes qui
sont sur la plate forme à travers le
monde qui sont additionnés et ensuite
les revenus du qui viennent des abonnés
ou de ses plates formes là sont
redistribués aux ayants droit au prorata
du nombre des côtes sur le total c'est à
dire si j'écoute pierre lapointe
beaucoup la wii est ce qu'il lui semble
le dire qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'argent par rapport à l'ensemble de son
écoute donc ce mois ci le mois où l'on
ait fait les calculs
effectivement si drake avait sorti un
album et des chansons sur spotify et
avait fait un tabac ou avait fait une
quantité immense proportion des coûte
proportionnellement le nombre des coupes
de pierre lapointe aurait diminué a donc
la valeur de son écoute n'est plus la
main n'est plus la même et fluctue d'un
mois à l'autre selon les sorties selon
l'achalandage selon nombre d'amendements
mais c'est quoi ce modèle là pourquoi
c'est comme ça ça a été à l'origine
basé sur un système donc de promotion
les premières licences qui ont été
nettoyés par spotify ou autres
plateformes d'ailleurs d'eux comme des
joueurs je pense ont été négociés avec
des méduses qui considérait ces plates
formes comme de superbes des outils de
promotion et de
deux découvertes en fait pour des
indépendants pour des nouveaux artistes
c'est les tarifs qui ont été négociées
et a donc des tarifs de promotion et non
pas des tarifs de diffusion comme ceux
qui ont cours de façon traditionnelle
avec un diffuseur par exemple comme
radio-canada ou comme sting ray ou comme
sirius oui je suis le lien droits
d'auteur il ya un droit qui touchait à
la vente a fait les droits sont reversés
aux détenteurs de la licence qui sont en
général donc les maisons de disques et
ensuite les maisons disent creux
distribuer ces revenus là aux ayants
droit il ans après mais on garde une
partie et redistribue soit à l'intérieur
de la fin de la chaîne de valeur des
contrats qu'ils ont avec les artistes
et donc pourquoi ça changerait pas
pourquoi on travaille repose sur un
modèle où les redevances serait
équitable par rapport au nombre
d'écoutés et c'est ça la vraie question
en fait c'est la question de l'équité
parce que on comprend mal quand on se
rend compte de ce que pierre lapointe
dit qu'au bout d'un million des coûts
qu'à seulement fait 500 temps d'un
encombrement comment le montrer si petit
et on comprend encore plus mal pourquoi
le montant devrait fluctuer dans un
écosystème qui dépendrait de très très
grand succès alors il ya des tentatives
en ce moment de remettre sur la table un
modèle centré sur les utilisateurs
c'est des heures qui a annoncé que ça le
premier à le mettre en place dès janvier
prochain en fait dès 2020 et la façon
dont ça fonctionne c'est que si vous
êtes abonné gerald et que
vous écoutez break jour et nuit
l'ensemble de votre abonnement va aller
en redevances à brec'h vous pouvez
écouter pierre lapointe une fois et donc
il ya seulement qu'une toute petite
partie du revenu vote amendement qui va
aller à pierre lapointe est par contre
si moi je m'abonne et que je n'écoute
que du pierre lapointe la totalité de
mon abri prix de mon abonnement serait
reversé donc à pierre lapointe ou à
toutes les autres artistes que je
voudrais
écoutez ce qui veut dire qu'au lieu de
soutenir par mon abonnement un artiste
que je n'écoute pas je soutiendrai où
vous soutiendriez directement un artiste
que vous écoutez de façon assidue
c'est ça le modèle centré sur
l'utilisateur bon alors spotify est une
entreprise suédoise il ya des grands
géants du web qui sont des entreprises
américaines
quelle est la portée de ce qu'ont fait
jusqu'où on peut aller dans une
modification du système quand on fait
des sorties publiques comme ça a été
fait hier soir au québec c'est très
difficile dans un contexte réglementaire
actuel effectivement parce que ces
entreprises ne sont pas des entreprises
canadien et un plus deux soeurs elles ne
sont pas soumises à la réglementation du
crtc par décision du crtc lui même à qui
on a régulièrement posé la question à
qui on a demandé de jouer de se pencher
sur le sujet et que ce statut est en
fait qu'il ne réglemente aurait pas
c'est ces plateformes du côté de
l'europe ce qui se passe c'est qu'on
tente d'évaluer quelle est l'activité
économique de ces entreprises là sur les
territoires et non pas de les imposer en
fonction du lieu géographique ou leur
siège social est situé
autrement dit une entreprise américaine
qui a une très grande activité
économique en france va être taxés sur
l'activité économique qu'elle a en
france et non pas sur le fait de
déclarer des profits en france parce
qu'elle a une entité juridique en france
c'est la première chose qu'il faudrait
faire à mon avis c'est de se rapprocher
donc de cette conception la de la
fiscalité qui est celle qui est
préconisée et qui commence à être
appliquée en euros maintenant est ce
qu'on peut considérer spotify comme
étant un diffuseur comme tous les
diffuseurs qu'on a toujours connu
jusqu'à maintenant équipes en ont pas en
ce moment parce qu'encore une fois la
crtc a décidé que non il faudrait en
arriver en fait ce modèle là et ça vaut
pour tous les autres diffuseurs et
toutes les autres plateformes de
diffusion de contenus culturels et
divertissement qui
kiki désabonner au canada parce que le
problème en ce moment c'est que spotify
ne se considère pas comme étant dans la
business de l'industrie musicale
il ya dans la business de la diffusion à
les diversifier vers la balado ce qui
veut dire qu'ils se positionnent en
marge du système comme s'il n'était pas
un partenaire de l'industrie musicale et
en plus de cela elle ne contribue pas
comme les diffuseurs radio canadien à la
création et au soutien l'industrie
musicale locale vit au facteur ovi music
action bien comité chez-nous dominic
simard et pierre trudel qui doit
remettre un rapport en janvier qu'est ce
qu'on doit attendre comme recommandation
qu'est ce que ça peut changer la
première des choses c'est d'agir vite
parce qu'en fait la diffusion en continu
les modèles d'affaires
en ce moment sont basées sur le fait et
sur l'espoir d'une croissance encore
très très très prenante pour de
nombreuses années encore il faut donc
agir maintenant avant que le modèle
d'affaires se cristallisent au profit
des très gros ceux qui sont les grands
bénéficiaires du système en ce moment et
qui va faire en sorte qu'ils ne
reviendront pas dans un système où il y
aurait une par terre en partage
différent des remous je suis un amorti
merci beaucoup